il ya des millions de médecins et de
cardiologues dans le monde qui ont reçu
cette semaine un avis de la part de la
prestigieuse american heart association
ça concerne l'obésité chez les enfants
et les maladies cardiovasculaires l'une
des chercheuses est avec nous ce matin
lapidiales québécoise julie st-pierre
spécialiste de l'obésité infantile
on l'a joint en direct à munich docteur
saint pierre bonjour bon matin merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes membre de
l'american heart association qui a émis
cet avis cette semaine donc faisant un
lien entre l'obésité et les maladies
cardiovasculaires chez les enfants
qu'est ce que vous dites mais
essentiellement dans cet avis
essentiellement on revient sur les
différents facteurs de risque qui
peuvent mettre un enfant au cours de son
développement hiver la vie d'adulte à
risque de souffrir de maladies du coeur
parmi ces enfants là bien sûr et les
enfants qui ont soif souffert de cancer
pédiatrique qui a les enfants avec des
malformations cardiaques
il ya les enfants qui souffrent de
diabète suis pas un type 2 mais la
grande nouveauté en fait ce pourquoi moi
je me suis battu sur ce comité
américaines là depuis les trois
dernières années c'est pour avoir
l'introduction du facteur de risque de
l'obésité chez les jeunes qui est
dramatique qui est une pandémie en fait
qu appelle tous les pays et c'est un
grand privilège pour toute l'équipe
d'avoir réussi à démontrer que ce type
est un facteur de risque qui peuvent
prendre au sérieux
partout dans le monde donc c'est très
important pour vous de sonner leurs
armes à ce sujet oui ça fait 15 ans que
je travaille avec des enfants qui
souffrent et le mot souffrance est
important de cette malade bullock et
sereine de préjugés et qui hypothèquent
la future vie d'adulte
il faut pas se le cacher on a des
enfants au québec qui souffrent de
maladies du foie gras de diabète de type
2 à des âges de 5,6 c'est un jeu qu'on
ne voyait jamais avant
ce sont des futurs consommateurs de
soins très important d'un point de vue
économique dans notre société
écoutez la fondation des maladies du
coeur dans les dernières années nous
faisait état qu'il ya à peu près pour 30
milliards de complications au canada 50
milliards dans dix ans il faut sonner
l'alarmé
parce que bien sûr nos enfants
seuls les moyens de tous nous crée t
dans le futur vous dites que c'est
répandu un peu partout dans le monde les
problèmes d'embonpoint d'obésité jury
plutôt que c'est un enfant sur trois au
québec
est-ce qu'on se dirige à votre avis vers
une crise de santé publique
en fait on a déjà les deux pieds dedans
ah ouais parce que je voudrais qu'on a
des enfants à 30% des enfants là au
québec ccq
c'est un chiffre là épouvantable on a 8
10% d'enfants qui souffrent d'asthme et
puis on a l'impression qu'ils ont tous
des pompes imaginer comment ça touche
énormément d'enfants donc cesser wim
crise de santé publique ça fait
longtemps qu'ils les gens le disent et
malheureusement ces enfants-là
actuellement ne sont pas traitées
autrement qu'avec des dons que ce soit
mes collègues à saint justin mes
collègues au children à québec au
saguenay
ailleurs on doit quitter ramasser des
sous pour être capable de traiter ces
enfants là dans ce système donc quelles
sont vos recommandations pour remédier à
la situation
ben on dit très bien dans l'article
c'est pas uniquement au québec quand
c'est aux états unis ses alliés en
afrique mais pas deux fois plus de
visites en afrique il y a dix ans qui
l'aurait cru et la recommandation qu'on
fait dans notre article pour le
traitement de l'obésité c'est que les
gouvernements que ce soit ici ou
ailleurs doivent s'investir de façon
massive dans les soins de santé
il ya des techniques des façons de
traiter ces gens là qui sont efficaces
la chirurgie bariatrique ça reste une
option pour certains patients en fin
d'adolescence
mais l'essentiel c'est d'essayer de lui
sauver avance et 80 % de ces jeunes ne
peuvent répondre à des thérapies
multidisciplinaire avec nutritionnistes
psychologues qui est également des
infirmières des kinésiologues qui sont
impliqués là-dedans donc c'est important
de soutenir ces équipes-là travers le
québec
et cet article légitimise en fait notre
notre action auprès des gouvernements
pour être capable d'avoir de meilleurs
soins pour les jeux wii vous ça fait
longtemps que vous vous impliquez pour
la cause entre autres que vous êtes
impliqué également
avec michelle obama pour faire bouger
les jeunes je n'ai malheureusement
jamais rencontré mais en 2008 2009
lorsque j'ai reçu mon fellowship
honorifique aux états unis pour
l'américaine wright j'ai eu le privilège
en fait de revoir le programme américain
le programme d'émettre des
recommandations est également en
partenariat avec l'association des
pédiatres américains et ce fut une
expérience extraordinaire elle avait
déjà actuellement de solution
malheureusement oui
donc ce que vous dites aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il faut avoir un financement plus
systématique pour contrer l'obésité chez
les jeunes c'est essentiel en fait si on
pense qu'un adulte sur deux souffre
d'embonpoint ou d'obésité ont tout pour
se mettre la tête dans le sable puis
continue de penser que ça affecte
seulement les voisins mais la
problématique pour non en fait en ce
moment c'est les préjugés un médecin sur
deux juge son patient obèse pense qu'il
n'a pas les moyens pour s'en sortir la
volonté alors que c'est totalement
pourri c'est une question d'éducation
donc on le voit bien avec nos patients
même les plus démunis qu'il ya des
choses à faire des merciers finalement
nous avons parlé ce matin en direct de
munich en plus d'acteurs julie st pierre
merci ça fait plaisir au revoir bonne
relâche au revoir